foreign
[Music]
Let's uh get a couple games in
if we can find a good opponent of course
you can play a couple games with Sasha
occasionally for a catch
hmm
I mean Alexander's just a very popular
name
think it's not the most popular but it's
one of the top three for sure
okay looks like I'm already in trouble
uh
what did I do
I have to say with a pawn here because I
have to try to go F4 and solidify the
structure of course I'm much worse here
but
is it it is
I agree that they don't I agree with you
completely and has agrees with you too
okay I'm gonna go B3 to restrict the
Knight here and then
probably it's better to go Bishop to
yeah it's hard to say probably Bishop to
D2 and then it'd be Rook C1
C1
okay Rick whoa
okay I can go Knight A4 Knight C5 I can
go H4 and expand on the other side
hmm
[Music]
okay do we take first I'm gonna Knight
C5 immediately
probably we take a 95.
yeah but now he wants Knight D7 so maybe
Bishop F5 I'm going the wrong direction
here let's just go
let's go rookie one for now
yeah buddy just because Bishop Buffet
this is really stupid of me
it's gonna get sharp here
this is probably all bad
but I'm gonna try to spice things up
with E6
Queen D5 he wants for 56 let's go 95.
oh he just takes it wow
I don't see that at all
good
okay gives me T5 though
it's actually there's no win here
probably should go Knight C4 quickly
oh maybe Knight D3 was better I don't
know
just take this guy
probably takes
okay probably we should push or should I
go maybe
let's push
um
[Music]
okay I'm not gonna get mated
here I'm gonna wait on time but I'm also
probably winning on the board here at
this point
I could have just played Knight takes G5
yeah Alex is very strong back in the day
okay I'm gonna invite him to play yeah
let's play a perk
ooh
Sasha
E5 Maybe
this is an unorthodox position I think
I'm just gonna play this like a perk
this Castle
H4 I I play H5 I'm not scared of that
I'm also not scared of long Castle yeah
he's gonna play this probably very
positionally would be my guess 92 Rook
C8
let's go Knight A5
okay let's get the bishop pair gotta be
good
it's probably gonna go okay D5
let's get the deploy the queen
Alamo
whoa another 10 subs from CEO and each
what is going on these last two days
we have Bombs all over the place thank
you CEO Anish for the another 10 Subs
damn girl
deep girl
Dina Dina voice
yeah the problem is I made all the like
easy moves now I need to figure out some
actual some maneuver but okay it's super
difficult but I'm gonna game okay
now he's just crushing me out
positionally
I really don't want to go A6 because
then my queen is almost trapped
but I'm gonna play it
okay it gives me a bit of a bailout
option
but I'm worse here simply
I'm gonna get crushed on the squares
yay
now I'm gonna have to look for tactics
here and just figure out a way to get
out of this
maybe E6 I don't know maybe H5 was a
mistake
not on eBay with five Subs holy
on each Geary gifting Subs
CEO of chesscom absolute train right
here
B4 and A5 can I get away with that
probably can probably can
can I though E5 maybe first and then A5
what about that
yeah he missed before okay E5 and then
A5
so that he has to move no but that was
I don't know if that was stupid or not
probably was
yes it was very stupid
it was very very very stupid
Shrek
and I'm walking on hot calls right now
could be lost
trying to go for peace activity
G3
B6
Bishop Page Six
probably some tactics here that I'm
blundering
okay I can draw with Bishop E3 probably
can I play for a win no
tftl theory is thank you
I really don't want to draw this game
but I'm gonna have to
okay maybe I can try to win this it's
not gonna be easy
foreign
oh my gosh
okay we gotta get that Bishop banish
that Bishop out of there
gotta banish it
[Music]
oh my gosh and I'm losing
I guess I'm wait am I losing no I'm
still okay
no I'm not a kid but maybe G5 oh wait a
second now suddenly I've got some
chances now it's got It's getting
unbalanced
let's let's see if Sasha can spend a
bunch of time here
thank you Kevin Richardson G5 is a big
move he goes Knight T3 okay Bishop E4 no
G4
my Bishop E4 now he blunders up Pawn no
he doesn't H4
I have six
oh man
let's go H3
did I blunder F7 no
yeah I guess I did I've wanted a piece
great
job
better run for the H2 Pawn
I'm gonna try for G3 hey blenders it
completely you missed that idea simply
I'm gonna win
thank you jackpot Josie tough
hard-earned Victory there
let's go
given Richardson jackpot Johnson we've
got so many people subscribing right now
this is awesome big time hype train
okay this is bad for black I think
it's supposed to be bad for black at
least
okay I guess I never know in these types
of positions whether to go Knight C3 a
Kavita with the five Subs holy smokes
girl
Kavita thank you for the five Cavita
now
thank you very much
think about sports what's UPS
PC repair fund indeed
okay girl that's a new one
Avita
okay let's go E5 probably a very bad
move but I want to resolve the tension
in the center
okay hey this is nasty why did I do that
again
there's literally no reason to do it I
just did it now I'm losing it
at least I'm preventing it from castling
CEO and Niche with another sub with 10
more subs 20 more sub jobs oh my God
this is insane
this is insanity
insanity
oh my gosh thank you thank you I
apologize I'm gonna lose this game I
think
and what a scuffed start to the Stream
yeah now he just castles this is this
went from being almost winning to being
losing like overnight I have to go Rook
F1 and castle like I need to figure out
a way to Castle kingside queenside here
yeah Queen before is very strong
yeah he finds it instantly oh my
goodness
I was hoping you wouldn't see that move
and he found it immediately
yeah it's just over
what a bad game
okay all in
trying my best here to generate some
chances
oh that was probably a mistake
wait whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
okay let's just keep the Queens
oh I should have traded oh
okay Queenie 4K T1 though
still in the game
for now
laughs
I'm just playing on intuition right now
okay now I'm up on time so I'm doing
well
let's get the king out of the out of the
D file
out of the swamp
um I could take him and take and flag
him
but at this point I think I'm playing
for a win
on the board
Knight F2 Bishop b394 Rook D3
C6 with B3
um let's go Knight D4
just trying to confuse him at this point
wow
you're just not gonna make it close game
okay let's try to play a smooth game
from start to finish
okay again he's gonna go for this
so C5 I didn't have a great experience
with let's see what he what he plays if
I play a perk
all right so he's gonna go probably for
early Bishop H6 or what
C4 so this is some sort of King's Indian
let's play this Leica King's Indian
we've basically transposed into a samish
no I have to go like this
yeah but this I kind of like if I take
it
go here maybe
muscles
Natasha's very good in these structures
but still
I've got some squares
oh
yeah but I blended this this is
this is very rough right now
okay at Queen D6 he goes to 53. I simply
have no way to defend this Pawn that's
the problem
um six tactics we need to create some
tactics here
yeah don't go for these structures
against Sasha so I'm just busted
I'm just busted
and do that especially G5
just loses
seven maybe
okay I gotta dial it back and just hope
pray basically again
I don't know why I'm so sloppy right now
but things up with my play
I'm trying to create tactical chances
when where possible
okay there he's got Bishop C5
let's go with this Rook
D4 tactics tactics no no no no
[Music]
oh wait Rook is hanging took me a while
to see that and the other one is also
hanging but maybe I shouldn't take that
one
um no I probably should
man this is not easy
okay probably should drop it back
I need to be very accurate here and very
fast
neither of which I've been thus far
okay Queen D4
queen of five I
[Music]
now 24
. and now I'm starting to make some
progress I think
yeah but now he gives me the check
where's the win
see it
rookie 4 was much better stupid
shouldn't matter though
um
oh man losing it
he doesn't have Perpetual there I saw
that
just gonna play some jibaba stuff
it should be too yeah
okay um it's just equal what am I why am
I playing like this I'm playing some
sort of cross between the London and the
jababa
and Sasha is having none of it he's like
take it and shove it like where the sun
don't shine
this is exactly how you don't play
against him no tactics
and it's just but I mean it is a very
solid position
so maybe we can play a long game and
outplay him
hmm
what about Bishop G5 is this stupid
probably is but
yeah it just goes Rick d8
what am I doing
okay it's not threatening to take on
if I may just Rook B1 defend the pawn
probably didn't even have to defend it
but I want to
look I haven't created a single threat
this game
awful
to go rookie one because he was
threatening Knight D2
at least I got get my Rooks out of the
line of fire at least I have a passer so
it's something
this is this game has been so not my
style
but you gotta be able to win games like
this too Hikaru wins games like this
it just takes takes me three oh my gosh
oh my Lance girl
takes takes me three
unbelievable
more Magic
okay wait wait wait let's not let's not
butcher this
okay I know for a fact that Rook B2 just
wins on the spot I'm just gonna freaking
play it
D I can play FV and it just depends the
game
yeah he likes this D5 move
Euphoria knights with the 10 size man
when it rains it absolutely pours
thank you Euphoria Knights appreciate it
10 Subs to the community and I blundered
queen A4 nice nice nice nice nice
great job man
thank you for your Knights appreciate it
win A4 is such a freaking annoying
little move by Sasha
annoying little a l m annoying little
move
huh I actually think
I need to be very very very careful here
that's what I'm going to say
I think Queen B8 I have to play because
Knight B5 I want Bishop D7
now maybe
A5 and Bishop D7 like this
okay now we gotta coordinate the Rooks
Rook C1 Rook C8 okay goes Bishop F1
in principle I don't mind the trade if I
can control the C4 Square again I'm
worse but position is very holdable
I'm putting them
okay he wants Knight C4
maybe we spice it up with A4 a little
bit
three first oh
gives me this though
Roxy one simply
okay I think takes make sense to start
or maybe Rook A2 just drive the rook and
try to go for activity on the queen side
and I blunder Knight C4
I just forgot about this move
now it's not the end of the world so the
question is which piece do we defend
with I would imagine
the bishop because I want the Knight
potentially to go to H5
oh are there no tactics here wait that's
a blunder I think
semi-blunder would be three
King F2
I can go back to C3
it's risky though because when the Rooks
are traded
and I'm gonna try it
MP3 makes sense
should page six is interesting but I
don't like it
let's see who only wants queen C4
maybe engineers and tactics
it's a very good move
I'm gonna move the king up actually
with its blender
okay I'm up for fun
not risking here
but can I win it
wait if he takes it should I go Knight
T5 or should I go GF
GF Bishop C7 95 no probably if he goes
the f I should play Knight T5
and then try to flag him there
was Knight D2
okay so here I go Bishop H4 oh he's got
this
um crap what do we go let's go here
sort of reshuffle my pieces and calm
down here team should be seven
let's get the King around to D7 for
defensive purposes
I get away with Knight T4 let's make him
think a little bit threatening Knight C2
check with a fork
yeah they made him think a lot unless
I'm learning some tactic here but I
don't see it
he's just not gonna make it at this rate
okay now I think
4 makes no sense here
because if he moves his Bishop I just
start pushing no this is winning
this is still in
[Music]
okay let's play D4 again thank you it's
Queen love
wait I did something wrong you're not
supposed to go H3 here that was stupid
thank you for the bits
good night to you
that was immensely dumb to play H3 I
confused the lines
hmm there's tactics though
at least there's the potential for
tactics
but I don't actually see where they are
yeah I blended this I I mean I didn't
blunder it I saw it but I I didn't do
anything about it
position is still pretty solid though if
it takes takes I'll play C3 and I'll
just milk that position
I mean I think I'm fine here I'm pretty
solid
not not fantastic but solid
okay Queen G3 defend
okay Bishop C7 Rook C8 should D6 Maybe
hmm
I'll do it I don't see a compelling
reason not to take this Pawn to be
totally honest
Bishop H6 was also interesting I think
he'll go Rook D5
yeah now we'll drop it back
then maybe stick a knight on C5 when the
time is right I also have the idea of
doubling Brooks on the E file and
solidifying C3
Bishop H6 is an idea too
okay I like the look of rookie 3 though
just to solidify everything he might
have G5 but okay if it works congrats
yeah actually why did I allow that that
was really stupid he doesn't play it
was kind of dumb to allow that
Bishop D6 what about that move
takes Knight takes
oh God
this one I did not see
I did not see that move that's a nice
tactic
what a move incredible
incredible move
and now I'm lost
but at least I feel at home
in a lost position
yeah the one game I outplayed
her tactically
that was an amazing I gotta I gotta hand
it to him
but I'm not ready to go gentle into that
good night if that makes any sense
I want to actually go gentle into E8
hey John
hey guys
I got a coffee here
no I don't see a defense he's got no
moves it's coffee
he's got no freaking moves it's
ridiculous
these Bishops are dominated
okay now I must be winning
okay let's do a little move repetition
here
just a little little procedure
a procedure
it's called a flagging procedure
oh
ideally I mean I could try to flag him
here but I don't want to flirt with that
but yeah I have to flirt with that
many is no chance
awful game but
yeah this F3 move okay let's go Knight
C6
that's B3 that's not a great move I
think
it's not a great move but I don't really
know the theory of this line
yeah no wait I knew I know this line
forget it I think
you're supposed to do here it's not C6
I think it is before
I think you're supposed to play before
and Sack this Pawn
yeah this reminds me of my stand for
days
those were the days those were those
were some amazing days
amazing but full of frustration
and now I'm I'm just this is just
can we get the structure and this time
I'm just down a pawn I don't even have
equal material no this decision to play
B4 was just short-sighted and awful
simply lost
so I've got to abide my time here and
wait pray for a tactical chance
which I'm not gonna get it appears
yeah blundered another Pawn
nice
hey yay
try this
everybody just goes there
I could have won on the spot there
oh he goes correctly with a pawn crap I
wasn't expecting that
looking for tricks here
seven still holding on for now
[Music]
okay A5
good move
[Music]
A6
and Rook A6 is not out of the question
I think this makes the most sense
about what this is lost
yeah she finds H4
crap
he's oh you can take my knight can't he
[Music]
that's the levy king walk
man he knows this Dragon I didn't
realize that Sasha was the Dragon
I think F4 is the idea
[Music]
I don't know I know this is the idea
that was taught to me by Gregory kaidana
my coach
it's like the only idea that I know in
the Dragon
and probably it fails okay let's think
yeah this is awful again
maybe Knight D5 I can just pile on the
pressure on the center this does look
awful
but it's also very combative
oh yeah I missed that move too
my gosh girl struggling here
to get any kind of play
out of the opening with either color
[Music]
okay why explain
foreign
in fact I played the dragon of black
against Darius version got crushed in
the US championship
yeah he's got this annoying move
actually which is kind of annoying
hmm
not so simple here
oh but I have this move maybe
or do I what was that yeah it just goes
for coup that was really stupid okay now
I can go Knight D1 let's just not get
checkmated there that's the goal
if I can Stave it out for a couple more
moves I'm fine I think Knight D1 just
wins
I don't see it I don't see it for him
even if he piles on the pressure yeah it
goes there
I'll go there
[Music]
oh yeah B3 was winning on the spot
wasn't I'm just not seeing anything
of that nature
does he have some tactics oh my God if
he has some taxes gonna be so triggered
okay um I think now just be three maybe
is it good guys a good guy things could
go it's just good girl I think he's good
rhyming I mean it's good guys good girl
run out now now King C1 I think Daniel
probably lose this with both colors but
okay let's take it I mean I I am up a
piece correct or am I hallucinating
and a bunch of Pawns
okay it takes he wants to take with a
queen I would imagine
foreign
[Music]
okay I think this Rook to C8 so I have
Bishop f8 in the event of Knight H4 and
Knight F5
just play Knight H4
okay BC is the right sensing actually
I like the look of BC here just grab the
pawn
and Bishop f8 that's why I played Rook
fc8
and I think at some point just D5 with
total pandemonium in the position
I'm just tempted to play netball style
at D5
I'll give it
but I do give it a thing
because I give a I'm gonna go here first
I give a girl too
okay he goes back
of course of course I had missed
okay
I hate this position actually
okay what's going on
just making random moves here
oh he takes I didn't see that move
wait I could have okay never mind
forget it
come on I'm down upon at the end somehow
snotty
okay maybe not
wow that was incredible tactics by Sasha
and he preserves a launch a lot of time
on his clock
okay takes a knight F4 is interesting
don't have to do that though I could go
Queen E6
you're like I'm gonna lose that end game
yeah I'm Gonna Keep the Queens my
intuition's telling me to keep the
Quinns on the board
[Music]
oh
okay I had Knight F6 I can play it
anyway
yeah it just says this
just amazing
yeah
I tried I mean I could have forced to
draw obviously but
I tried to win
I mean I tried to win could have made a
draw better a petition
yeah I mean I also could have not
sacrificed my queen
it was idiotic
and I'm losing a second game
[Music]
unless I can go E5 then everything
changes
I think E5 is a very strong threat
no Chad is always like that John if I
don't win 75 in a row it's like I can't
satisfy people
I think I want something like 35 or 40
in a row before this game by the way
but who cares I lost one out of a
hundred so
[Music]
I don't know what to say you guys are
tough
[Music]
I had a chance at The Rook takes B6 yeah
some people
expect a lot which you absolutely should
should expect a lot I expect myself to
win more games
[Music]
I mean I've adopted him before I think
it's not such a big deal
okay quick bathroom break
I'll be right back
okay let's go
what's the point of playing somebody
beat by such a one Mark I mean
dude
what do you want me to say he's a GM
just can't win with some people I just
can't win
okay let's play some weird Hodgson
system type thing I think it's what it's
called when you get the bishop out like
this
that is the game I lost
that is that is the
structure that I lost with just go A6 or
something
[Music]
okay H6 Bishop G6
now b4a5
and I don't like any of this I need to
move I'm I'm sleeping
Matt Sasha's playing this so quickly
okay let's go Bishop H5 try to provoke
G4 and then go back to G6
okay Bishop G6 we're just gonna keep
dancing so
might as well just trade I could go D5
but I don't like those slop structures
and particularly I prefer to keep the
sort of
King's Indian flavor of the position so
let's go E5 Maybe
what should I take with probably the pun
yeah but now again on the clock I'm just
getting massacred
that was a pretty questionable move
yeah now I'm in trouble again
okay
[Music]
foreign
happens from time to time
so yeah
all right
[Music]
okay
am I missing something
hmm
[Music]
so yeah yeah go back to sleep
all right all right
I've never even seen Sasha over the
board
yeah I have no idea what to play here
because he's gonna go C5 and he's gonna
be better
I'm gonna go Knight A4 it's a weird move
but I think it's interesting because see
okay let's Bishop A6 wait tactics
smells like tactics and I can't see
anything
and there's back rank mates I need to be
careful about
okay this is fine
this is I have scuffled last couple
games maybe some bullet after this I
don't know we'll see
oh and I blundered or did I he blundered
takes
you blundered a piece just not holding
the tension
no you no you no no you no I blunder no
he blundered no I blundered I bungled I
just totally totally just totally
Bungalow complete bogalish so Bungalow
my gosh
now promising that I lose it's just how
I'm losing cause I'm losing to an idiot
I'm just gonna try to spank this loser
now
all right Queen D1
yeah I mean it's about Diana 21 I mean
though I mean that's brown Dion 3200 you
know the In classical chess Stanford
okay
um I am of a freaking piece dude
I have nothing to say
yeah he plays Instinct instinctually so
when I get him into tactics he blunders
a lot but there's certain positions
where he's just like Unstoppable
so you have to avoid those types of
positions
okay I'm gonna allow Bishop okay goes
for the perk he goes for the classical
perk this is going to be a fascinating
affair
okay I think B5
hope I don't get check committed here
okay E5 I don't like actually because he
can Castle later although I've seen
people play E5 and such now let's go E5
let's go E5 why did I do that I was
stupid
yeah just castles the hell
what the heck Daniel
okay maybe I can make this work with
some Queen A5 startsy
I guess he goes King B1
then I go Bishop E6 or something I don't
know
okay
this is a serviceable position I think
this is serviceable
Channel your inner Valley Girl
I have literally no words
dude I wanted the Taylor Swift concert
the other day it was so good
like oh my God it was like literally so
good like I cannot even it was like that
good
okay
[Music]
yeah that could uh
it is probably my most accurate
impression
okay which came in which game which game
in the Caped game and like a trip to
keep the game okay
maybe someone will keep it okay but okay
okay six
Valley Girl by Frank Zappa now I know
who that is vaguely but no
it was like literally so lit
who are all these players on who like
joined nine hours ago or whatnot and
then they're like 2 900. there's so many
of them
okay there's so many of them I can't
even
literally I can't even
literally
like yawn
okay
but there's tactics very simply um uh
it's very simple yeah okay okay Daniels
is the only tactic I mean okay
he only does Tactics yeah because okay
which gave it okay
to K
okay
my slavo is amazing sadly don't do it
often for good reasons wait why would I
not do it all well no I do it it's just
hard to do it I have to focus and it's
the focus when you take the ideology and
you convert it into the old um
Jewish joke is that a golf uh four
because the promise nobody knows who I'm
doing so people just think I'm like
having a stroke or something
it's actually a really good impression
thank you
and slow on and so on yes and so and so
on and so on
oh you mother he doesn't see it
he's such a mother
and so on and so on
okay now maybe we take and Sean and Sean
it's like ideology and you take this
phone and now we take this other Pawn
[Music]
this ideological
um um
and so on and so on
[Music]
but what am I doing next because okay
now we try this move
this is trash Boy by me
wait wait wait
calm down I've got plenty of time relax
girl
I'm gonna play this line I I used to
always play this
it's avoiding Theory basically
[Music]
okay
how I seen the recent shows broad Tic
Tacs no I don't really do tick tock
I know it's very unvalley girl like me
did I saw it on Tick Tock it was so lit
[Music]
thank you
that is so triggered okay let's go GF
it's listening to this like super toxic
streamer like to this impression of me
and
like so annoying
so annoying I'm telling you
okay
um
something like this okay
okay
there is pointing up together okay
okay I don't actually know what to do
here so I know I'm
all joking aside
what if I go like this
I thought I have this one though
wait why didn't I go E7 first it's a
good question isn't it
I guess he goes F6 I don't know what to
do
I mean C7 Queen C7 Knight C7 rookie
seven Rook D7 Rook t7 Ed King F7
Knight F6 though I guess
foreign
tell me
tell me what I missed
enlighten me oh wise ones
Bank
thank you
wait a second
cool 15 games ladies and gentlemen
that's how we do it
foreign
[Music]